people in brazil have taken to the
streets to protest against president
bolsonaro's handling
of the coronavirus pandemic the death
toll is expected to reach half a million
shortly
and that led to tens of thousands to
demonstrate against his policies in
major cities
the president's handling of the crisis
is the main focus of the protests
but some are also demanding action on
issues like the destruction of the
rainforest
let's cross straight now to
correspondent matthias ebert in rio de
janeiro
these aren't the first nationwide
protests against president bolsonaro so
what's different this time
in 2020 and in the beginning of this
year
people many brazilians showed their
protests by hitting their pots on their
balconies
now part of them is on the street and
they are angry and then demand
an increase of the financial assistance
for
poorer family the corona assistance and
they're angry because of the corona
policy of president
bolsonaro he bought the vaccine too
late and for this um the vaccination
campaign started really slowly
only in recent days it accelerated
and so yesterday brazil brazil achieved
the number of more than two million
doses applied
per day for the first time
and quite apart from the vaccination
situation which seems to be
perhaps improving president bolsonaro
continues to reject
protective sanitary measures so are
things going to continue to get worse
i think that the population here in
brazil will only be vaccinated
until the end of this year and um
this is really a pity that it takes will
take so long
therefore the numbers don't decline and
experts
estimate that um the reason is because
in many poor areas um
foremost there are many people still ign
agglomerations
they have no other choice buses are
packed full of workers and that's one
reason the other one might be
the the circulation of mutations
new mutations possibly dangerous ones
not only here in brazil also in the
neighboring country peru
and in all this time bolsonaro's
popularity as you know
has continued to dwindle what does that
mean for his hold on power and ability
to govern
yeah polls show that brothel sonar is
really under pressure regarding the
elections next year in october 22
ex-president lulada silva is top-ranked
in recent polls he
got back his political rights recently
so he's
uh the candidate to um to win
and uh the opposition that supports him
exactly the people behind me now
protesting in these days
and the protests might go on in the next
month
mathias ebert reporting for us from rio
de janeiro thanks so much